so let's actually talk about the science
here and as specifically as it relates
to some of your prior work in food right
and you talked about things like
nutritionism right and we got into this
weird point with food where you know
we've invented white bread yeah where we
took things out and then we really took
out the healthy things and then we had
nutrient-enriched white bread and so as
you put it you you put the the problem
on the solution in the same packet maybe
packaging and so the point being that we
had was clever science but maybe at all
along nature was had it right to begin
with so let's make an analogy here to
mushrooms
we're doing all this research on
psilocybin is it possible that if we
focus on this one nutrient yeah the
psilocybin are we missing something
important in the whole it's completely
possible I don't know the answer for
sure I mean there are actually two
chemicals in psilocybin there's solution
and thriven but there may be other
compounds too and they may be relevant
and they and also there may be different
compounds that you know philosophy
cubensis which is the main mushroom most
people use is only one of a hundred and
fifty different psilocybin species does
as arrestins have other stuff in it it
seems to have some slightly different
effects so and we know this in cannabis
right you know we know there are two
famous cannabinoids THC and CBD but
there are many many more when people
started fooling around with beta
carotene or you know these they thought
that you know the key to the carrot is
this this antioxidant called beta
carotene and they and they turned it
into a pill and they gave it to people
thinking it would help them and in fact
it hurt them the death rate from cancer
went up in people who were eating the
supposedly good nutrient well it turns
out that they're you know 49 other
carotenes in a carrot and and we haven't
studied most of them so we should be
very respectful of the of the mushroom
as nature gives it to us
and at least explore the possibility
that there are other things going on
that are valuable it's you know there
are cases when you know we synthesize
things successfully and effectively but
our tendency is is to is reductive and
you know for science you need to be
reductive right you need to isolate that
chemical to perform a drug trial but I
think we should be aware that there may
be you know same the difference between
peyote and mescaline I mean you know has
anyone really explored that I don't know
the answer but the other parallel from
food that I think is really relevant and
I'm glad you brought this up is eating
alone mmm you know we one of the one of
the main trends in western food is the
move from eating as a communal act to
eating as something you do in the car
you know 46 percent of meals are eaten
alone now 20 percent or in the car and
this kind of atomized individualistic
eating turns out not to be very good for
your health because people eat too much
from they eat alone whereas when you eat
at a table with other people other
things are going on you're talking
you're conversing and and you eat in a
more moderate way and so there's
something about socializing an
experience that can make it healthier
and that may be true with psychedelics
too
yeah I'm glad you're bringing this up
actually and we look in the traditions a
lot of the time psychedelics are taken
in groups ayahuasca circles yessum you
know or in the case of if we go to Gabon
and we talk about it boga it's actually
hit the communal aspect of that is
almost reversed there's one person in
getting initiated and this may not be
true in all bleating traditions it's
very diverse in itself but there's
initiate and then the entire community
is around you supporting you and so the
community aspect not to mention
integration and all this other aspect
and and right now with the FDA approval
process what we're going toward is a
single person with two guys which seems
it's a single person but not alone not
alone right like eating with the
chaperone at McDonald's but we don't
right
you know it's not really but
but we really don't have a necessarily
right now a lot of sites a group
psychedelic work which I think well I
but I I think that's coming I think one
of the ways you'll deal with the
inefficiencies of two therapists and one
person and I think there's some
proposals of foot in at least I know in
Europe
Bob Jesse you'll send me a memo about
this later if I'm wrong that of looking
at the possibility of doing group
psilocybin as a way to make you know
that two therapists could actually work
on six people at once yeah or eight
people and I think that's worth
exploring I mean certainly that's the
ayahuasca model you're right and I know
what maps has a study for couples
therapy actually yes where one person in
the couple has PTSD and so and they're
actually treating the couple
collectively because they're both
affected by the PTSD and this gets into
the broader dynamics of socially you
know we're not just isolated individuals
yeah that that's true of the cancer
studies - they're people like Katherine
MacLean who makes the argument and it's
a very good argument that the caregivers
can benefit just as much from psilocybin
therapy as the person who's dying and
that it's a whole constellation that's
affected by that by that event and the
grief and there's actually a study of
AIDS survivors with psilocybin that's
about to start at San Francisco and that
is treating the survivor not the not the
patient so I think there's you know
there's so much more to be learned and
there's so many exciting experiments to
do and what's what's really wonderful is
that this space has been created by
these pioneers and the end the you know
the willingness of the FDA to go along
with this because they have been
basically encouraging of the research in
recent years that we're gonna learn a
lot we're gonna learn a lot about the
mind and about you know the way it works
and the way it sometimes fails to work
in the next few years and that
psychedelics in addition to being
interesting of themselves are gonna
prove to be a very powerful tool for
understanding addiction and dying and
depression and anxiety and the mind and
consciousness and that's to me is really
exciting you know Stan Grof had that the
the legendary psychedelic psychiatrist
who's still with us he said once and I
remember reading this early in my
research and thinking that is ridiculous
he said that psychedelics or LSD would
be for the study of the mind what the
telescope was for astronomy and what the
microscope was for biology
it was really an audacious thing to say
especially then but actually I no longer
think that's crazy at all
I mean I think that psychedelics do have
very important things to teach you